I will ask you a question that I think is interesting.
Did you happen to be in a room at room temperature,
say about 70 degrees Fahrenheit (21 degrees Celsius),
looking at a glass of water,
in which suddenly a cloud of ice appears?
I guess you did not happen to see something like that.
Naturally, you can not see spontaneous ice formation,
especially at room temperature,
because it is above the freezing temperature of the water.
But my question is - why not?
This does not contradict
none of the physical laws of Newtonian physics.
Neither the first law of thermodynamics.
Let's think how this could happen.
Imagine some water molecules
in a liquid aggregate state.
I have some water molecules in the liquid state.
I'll do a lot of them.
They have a certain temperature.
Remember, the temperature is related to the average kinetic energy.
But each of these molecules will have its own speed,
own impulse.
Everybody will move
in different directions.
They also have hydrogen bonds with each other.
This is why the water is liquid at room temperature,
and not in the gaseous state.
We have hydrogen bonds between molecules.
But I will not stop at this for a long time.
Imagine that all molecules bounce in random directions,
but there is some probability,
they interact in the right way,
maybe this molecule is here
can hit this in the right way.
So it transmits most of its impulse to the faster molecule.
That's why this molecule loses its impulse and slows down.
While this happens,
one of the other molecules can
to pass the bulk of its impulse to some other molecules.
This will slow down.
He'll be late.
Everybody will have a lesser impulse.
And then perhaps this, right at the same time
can do the same.
He 's late.
Then all the other molecules to which impulse is transmitted,
will move faster.
This has received an impulse.
That too.
This is an impulse.
This one too.
And this impulse is transmitted.
Now these molecules here
have a small enough impulse and
slow enough,
so the hydrogen bonds
take control and can begin
to form a grid.
We can say that the molecules become cold enough,
to freeze.
So these molecules turn into ice.
Why can not this happen?
In the description I just spoke only about colliding
molecules that impart impulses.
I am talking about energy that is not created and is not being waxed.
This seems consistent with the first law of thermodynamics.
It seems that in theory
spontaneous ice formation is possible.
But perhaps it is possible to look at the issue in another way.
Maybe we can start with a system,
which is relatively homogeneous.
There is an average temperature.
But perhaps it is possible to form a cold pocket,
when warming the rest.
Maybe initially all water is 70 degrees Fahrenheit.
Everything I show you is at the neutral 70 degrees Fahrenheit.
But maybe there's a chance ...
We have no creation or loss of energy,
but spontaneously part of the energy in the environment,
can go to the outside and warm it up.
I will color this in a different color.
Maybe all this water outside ...
maybe this is a painting of the water seen from above.
Maybe all of this water gets hot.
And all the water in the middle is cold.
But they have the same
common kinetic energy.
So we have not created or lost energy.
Just spontaneous
we managed to transfer energy from the middle to the outside.
And even when the water in the middle became a bit colder,
we could carry more energy
from cold water to hot.
We get this sort of arrangement.
In fact, this seems possible
according to the physics we know so far.
But some deep-seated people like these gentlemen here,
this is Carnot, considered the father of thermodynamics.
Kelvin, Rudolf Clausius.
They have repeatedly found that this is not happening in nature.
Especially Kelvin and Clausius.
They say, "Look, we do not watch
heat transfer from cold to warm. "
"And if we do not see him,
let's add a second law of thermodynamics. "
The second law on thermodynamics is based on empirical observations.
The second law on thermodynamics,
according to Rudolf Clausius,
I will paraphrase it,
says we do not see spontaneously ...
I will write it.
Second Law on Thermodynamics.
He said we did not see a spontaneous transfer
of heat from cold to hot zones.
Second law on thermodynamics:
no spontaneous transfer ...
We can use work
in things like cooling systems,
to make the heat flow
from cold to warm, to cool something.
But there is no spontaneous heat transfer from cold to warm.
I will emphasize warmly
with orange here.
This law is based on observations,
because we do not see this happening spontaneously,
we can not see the water suddenly organizing in
separate warm and cold zone,
which would become so cold,
to freeze spontaneously.
But if we put ice in the middle of the room
at room temperature we see the opposite.
We'll see a heat transfer from ...
I'll draw a glass here.
We will see heat transfer
from warmer to cooler areas.
Here are cubes of ice.
And that's water.
Here's the water.
We will see heat transfer in the opposite direction.
This is an empirical observation,
which seems to be true when tested experimentally.
But why is it happening?
It turns out there is
some very, very, very unlikely
this will happen
in the real systems we are talking about.
And thermodynamics is more a science of systems,
not the individual molecules we talked about.
And when we talk about a system,
we are talking about many more molecules,
many more actors from these three molecules here.
If we talk about the number of molecules in a glass of water,
we are talking about a number of 20, 24, 25 zeros,
depending on the size of the glass of water.
We have a huge, huge number of molecules.
Statistical ...
Statistics were not thought
to the time of Boltzman ...
But statistically, the chance of this happening is small.
Especially when we are not talking about just three molecules,
but we talk about a lot, many more than three.
So many molecules that we can never see something like this.
Let's look at things at the molecular level.
Do not just look at the macro level.
So we will understand the reason.
If you have a vessel.
I will draw a court here.
If you have a vessel,
and on the left,
we will start with several molecules that are warm.
They have high kinetic energy.
These molecules here
have high kinetic energy.
These molecules.
And on the right side of the court
we have some molecules that are the same type,
but have low kinetic energy.
Their temperature ...
On average they have low kinetic energy.
There may be some that have high kinetic energy,
but the average kinetic energy is low.
We see,
that the temperature here is lower.
I'll write it down.
The right side has a low temperature.
The left side has a higher temperature.
What will happen?
These molecules can interact,
to collide.
Molecules with high kinetic energy
will strike at others with low kinetic energy.
And all these molecules will mix.
But even if they did not mix, these molecules would hit those
and to carry their impulse.
So over time we will get
a system that looks like this.
All molecules will have
medium kinetic energy.
There will still be differences in their kinetic energies,
but they will not be separated in this way
between left and right.
All molecules will mix
and we will see that neither left nor right
will have a higher temperature.
What is the end result?
We had energy transfer
from warmer molecules to cooler ones.
Therefore, the energy we are talking about is warmth.
We denote the heat with Q.
We have transferred energy from warm to cold.
Statistically unlikely, very unlikely,
nearly impossible,
this is an infinitely small chance to happen
but it was not observed, to go backwards.
We are talking about many, many, many,
millions, millions, millions, millions of molecules.
We will see those with higher average kinetic energy
to mix and deliver it
of those with lower kinetic energy.
That is why we can say,
"Hey, we do not see a spontaneous heat transfer
from cold to warm ".
The transfer always goes
from warm to cold.